[Music]
hey everybody there's a whole bunch of
thor ragnarok that's been dropping today
talk about hella and infinity war as
well as what's happening between the
films thor ragnarok is like the last big
one to set up what's going on during
infinity war
so because tickets just went on sale for
this let's say the giveaway this week
for Marvel is gonna be for thor ragnarok
imax tickets so all you have to do to
enter that'd just be a subscriber leave
a comment on this video so we need to
talk about post credits scenes I think
we've actually already seen a version of
one of the Thor Ragnarok post-credit
scenes assuming that there's gonna be
multiple in the way that guardians had
multiple post credits scenes spider-man
homecoming had multiple scenes at the
end of the movie so it makes sense that
they do the exact same thing but whereas
most of the last couple of films
especially guardians of the galaxy are
mostly self-contained with their post
credits it seems like they've been
saving most of their mythology juice for
thor ragnarok like thor is one of the
original Avengers he's one of the most
powerful people in the universe assuming
that there will be upgrades during Thor
Ragnarok so we can speculate on how we
think the Thor is going to defeat hella
how they're going to invoke the final
infinity gem and lead into what Thanos
is going to do as he assembles the
Infinity Gauntlet but based on the
infinity war trailer it seems like the
guardians run into him in outer space
and it's sort of an altar on Star Wars
situation where they're trying to go to
a certain place but all they find is
debris and we don't know whether or not
this is actually Asgardian space that
they're in where Thor lands on their
windshield or if it's somewhere else in
the galaxy but suffice to say everybody
is going to get wrecked there will be a
form of Ragnarok and Thor looks like he
barely walks away from it but they did
say that the character would be
fundamentally changed and there's no
going back that's the language that they
used you can make a couple of
assumptions based on his comic book arcs
and how he eventually takes Odin's place
as king of Asgard whatever that winds up
looking like when Ragnarok is done
there's a very Game of Thrones idea
who's going to be the skeleton sitting
on the throne how bad does Loki want to
be king of Asgard that he would kill
himself
to achieve that but just based on the
way this infinity war footage reads it
sounds like it's right at the end of
Ragnarok it feels like more of a
Ragnarok scene than it feels like an
infinity war scene like all the stuff
later in that trailer when you hear
thatõs is coming to earth he steps out
of his ship and Iron Man standing there
that all feels like stuff that happens
later in the movie but it sounds like
they're using the very very end of Thor
Ragnarok to just tea that up because
it's coming out in May next year
Thor drops at the beginning of November
so it's really just a couple months
before infinity war drops in by the time
you're actually sitting down to watch
Ragnarok you will have seen the first
genuine infinity war trailer whatever it
looks like it'll probably be a little
bit different from that comic-con
footage but part of the other reason why
people think that this might be
connected to Thor Ragnarok is is because
one of the producers gave this quote and
I'm just reading his quote here where he
says we're definitely leaning into Jack
Kirby more heavily than guardians there
are elements of guardians that will work
their way into our film both
stylistically in narratively meaning
that guardians stuff will be part of the
story of what's happening at Thor
Ragnarok I'll explain what that means in
a second but then he goes on and says in
the sense of that like all the
earthbound heroes feel like they're
living and breathing the same air we're
certainly doing that now in outer space
it feels in a very MCU way that we're
all living and breathing the same air
meaning that the guardians has typically
been off by itself like you haven't seen
a lot of interaction with human people
with a very brief scene around a Dairy
Queen in guardians to
but for the most part you haven't seen
any interaction with the other Avengers
franchises and that sounds like it's
changing now I believe they're talking
more about the Grand Master in the
collector like the collectors workshop
is a new attraction at Disney it looks
like it actually shows up somewhere on
Sekar here the architecture is very
similar in there both elders of the
universe they're brothers in that sense
they're not literal brothers but it
sounds like they're going to explain
them as Celestials the same way they did
with ego the Living Planet so like in
the comics ego is in the celestial but
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe he is
and that will explain why they've been
around for so long why they're so
powerful yet they seem so ridiculous
they just grow an extremely eccentric
over the billions of years that they've
been alive so let me know in the
comments they have a bunch of
post-credit scenes during thor ragnarok
do you think that the infinity war one
will literally be this guardians of the
galaxy scene and that will be the
connection to how they meet up with the
other a-list Avengers the interesting
thing to note though is that there's no
Hulk in this scene so we end the film
with four big characters we have Hulk
Thor Valkyrie and Loki they're just
assuming that Odin is floating around
somewhere else so if we're only seeing
Thor in this scene here it doesn't
answer what happens to Hulk because he's
definitely an infinity war Loki shows up
later in the trailer with the tesseract
and then Valkyrie is somewhere in the
movie but we don't know how she pops up
we just know that Tessa Thompson was
seen on set filming infinity war scenes
and on top of that we actually learned
that inside the props room for thor
ragnarok like on the set in the props
room there was an Infinity Gauntlet
picture on the wall like as if the
Infinity Gauntlet would show up during
thor ragnarok at some point now there's
the one in Odin's vault from the first
Thor movie but Kevin Feige kind of said
that they did that scene before they
mapped out the Marvel Cinematic Universe
so everybody's always been like which
hand do stano's where Don the glove that
he has at the end of age of Ultron is
different from the gloves it's in Odin's
vault so people are just taking the
Infinity Gauntlet in Thor Ragnarok is a
sign that Thanos will show up himself at
some point but I think a lot of us
assume that a long time ago like he has
to pop up at least a little bit before
infinity war so that you can bridge the
just a little bit and the interesting
thing too is a lot of people are
wondering about hella because she's the
goddess of death in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe does that mean that she'll also
be the comic-book death from the
Infinity Gauntlet storyline so they're
two slightly different concepts the
death that Thanos serves or is in love
with is a cosmic concept beyond
space-time but the thing about hella is
that in the comics there was actually a
brief romance with Thanos recently so it
was like they're trying to tie those
characters together Early's get
audiences ready for the idea of that in
regardless of where she pops up during
the first or second infinity war film I
mean they're two different films but
it's really like to Thanos based films
she might just show up in the second one
and fill that death role or at least be
one of his partners if they don't
outright refer to her as death or try to
make her appear as she does in the comic
but as for speculation on that honestly
I think the Cate Blanchet was such a
huge get for the Marvel Cinematic
Universe that they're gonna try and use
her as best they can so if there was
space for her they're definitely
bringing her in because she is one of
they're a list actors you don't let
you're a list players ride the bench
during the world series of comic book
movies and that's what infinity war is
it's meant to be the biggest thing ever
it's happening during Marvel Studios
10th anniversary so it's not just a big
deal for comic book fans it's a big deal
for Marvel itself so here's the cool
thing I know like I've talked all about
the post-credits scene theory but they
also revealed a whole bunch of more
information about the characters during
Thor Ragnarok and what's going on let me
know if you want me to do a video for
that I don't really consider it spoilery
they just talked about how they combined
a couple comic book characters for
specific people in a couple other really
cool things about how it weaves with the
other films as well as the mythology of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe so if you
want me to do a video for that this
weekend just let me know in the comments
but i'll name the winner of that imax
ticket giveaway the next time I post a
Marvel video so while you wait for
everything you can click here for my
other infinity war trailer breakdown
it's a little bit longer and you can
click here to learn about all the new
people they just cast on the Titans
night
TV show thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight